i guess can you
walk me through like the procedure
of taking what you call a shot
yeah so um
or that or that shot in particular um
i'll actually do the first one because
that one was is one that's clear in my
mind
you know what the procedure was and it's
the process training these procedures
there's a checklist that you have to run
there's uh we have a safety observer who
sits there and makes sure that we run
the checklist and everything's within
regulations and according to the rules
of engagement and law of arm conflict
um so in the first one
uh i showed up to work
and my we have something called monthly
currencies where like you have to
you have to take a shot once a month or
run through the checklist to pretend
that you're taking a shot
and all sorts of stuff well my currency
had ran out
and they were like all right we're going
to put you in the seat and make you do a
real shot
and i show up get in the seat
and we run through the checklist
procedures
but what happened this one was probably
more interesting because
they were there was a convoy that was in
engagement
with taliban troops and they were on
firing from the top of the hill
underneath this
tree and they had us the person that was
in the seat before me
had set everything up to take the shot
so i get in the seat after this guy
and uh we're getting ready to take the
shot and we get a call from the jtac
that
says that the um
the missile impact would have
uh less of a result than what we want
from the hellfire missile so we're going
to have the f-16s that
are in the area drop a gpu a ground
uh guided bomb you which would have a
bigger
impact and so as we're monitoring this
conflict going down the
f-16 gets in contact with us and says we
found
three people 10 clicks to the south by
southwest
put your eyes on these locations this
location
so we move our we move our video feed to
this location
and we see these three individuals
walking down the road
and they can definitely hear this fight
going on like there's bombs exploding
guns going off grenades all sorts of
stuff and they look
terrified like they look like they're
you know
they're walking it's probably see
it was probably really early in the
morning maybe like
five o'clock six o'clock in the morning
in the dark oh yeah and so these there
were three individuals
two of them were walking and talking
together and you could see
their hand movements and and all these
types of things
and uh um the third person in the back
was lagging behind and he was he could
probably hear the f-16s in the area he
was probably listening
and um so the as soon as we put eyes on
these guys
the screener who is the intelligence
dude who was my job originally that was
the job i trained for
is watching this video feed and
confirming what's on the video feed and
he says we got three individuals with
weapons
and the jtac says confirmed weapons you
are cleared hot
and cleared hot means you are cleared to
engage these individuals
at your discretion and so the pilot
gives a two-minute call saying that
we'll be ready in two minutes to pull
the trigger
we run through the checklist we power up
the missile
we point the laser and the jtac says
point
the miss the laser between the two the
feet of the individuals in the front
because we'd rather get two than three
so point the laser and and
if if i'm gonna give a little background
information of my emotional state at
this time
um so my very first mission i saw
a convoy hit an ied and
i heard there's cries over the radio for
medical help
and basically all we could do was sit
there and watch them so i had this
i had this
you know programmed hate into me you
know i watched our own guys die
people on our own team die i want to
[ __ ] kill these guys
i want them to die i want them to to
suffer the consequences for hurting us
and um
there's a difference between killing out
a survival and killing
out of conflict and killing out of hate
because of an ideology and
when we when i re i was so laser focused
on these guys and i wasn't really
actually sure if i was able to do it
even though i felt all this
this emotional turmoil inside of me
um when the missile finally impacted
and hit uh you know it was the the
missile comes off the rail
in 1.5 seconds 1.3 seconds after it
comes off the rail
it hits the sound barrier so it's sonic
booms
but because the missile takes so long to
get to target
the kinetic energy of the missile slows
down that the sonic boom hits the target
about four to six seconds before impact
so the guy that was behind
everyone else heard the sonic boom and
runs towards the other two and we ended
up getting all three
right so the first two
people were in pieces
and you could see the body parts
everywhere and the third guy
had his leg one his right leg cut off
right above the knee and
i watched him bleed out um
and that was you know when
you hurt some i've never heard before
that i never hurt him
even though i was a wrestler i never i i
got into a couple fights in high school
but i never
hurt someone right i just defended
myself
this didn't feel like defending myself
this felt like straight up murder
like i watched the guy the guy bled out
he was rolling around on the ground i
can only just imagine
what he was thinking right like i'm i he
knew he was dying like you can tell he's
like rolling on the ground holding his
leg
and the people on the watching our video
feed were like
keep eyes on we just want to see if
anyone comes up and picks up the body
parts and
so i kept my camera on it and we
watched this guy in infrared
turned from a hot blob
with his blood squirting out of his leg
going
pooling underneath him and we watched
them
cool down enough so that they became um
uh no different from the ground that
they they died on and it was
a january so uh actually uh what
what's the date today is 20th okay so
six days will be my 15th
year anniversary a 16-year
14 year anniversary from when i snow 15
years holy [ __ ] 20 21
yeah so be 15 years since my first
uh hellfire missile shot um jesus
and uh and i remember it as clear as if
it
happened yesterday no
um and after like
you know you never really think that you
can do it until it happens and after it
happened
um i was devastated like i was in i was
in shock
like i felt like i just did something
that i had no right to do
you know i took another human being's
life in such a gross way like they had
no way to fight back they had no way to
to i didn't look them in the eye i
didn't know who they were i didn't see
their face we just
ended their life and i watched a guy
slowly drain
his life out
and afterwards i left like i laughed
when people were celebrating in my
squadron people were like high-fiving
themselves as if they're like yeah we're
winning the war on terror yeah high five
yeah congratulations but i felt nothing
but sickness
in me and i left
and uh as i was driving i drove off base
and i called my mother and i cried to
her and i
as as a young man like i cried and i was
like i can't believe i did this i can't
believe that i
i did it i felt so sick um and i called
her every
after every shot to to tell her this and
the advice that she gave me was you know
i know that it's a horrible thing
but your being there and feeling bad
about it is a good thing because it
means that you'll make sure that
the wrong people don't need to die the
wrong people aren't going to be killed
but as i look back on as i reflect on my
time in the military
i'm not sure if there was a right person